FROM NEW YORK CITY.
>> Sean: THANKS.
REPORTING FROM TONIGHT, WELCOME
TO "THE STORY" SIX.
I CAN MOMENTS AGO,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WRAPPING UP A
HUGE RUCKUS RALLY IN KENTUCKY,
WE WILL HAVE ALL THE HIGHLIGHTS
TONIGHT.
DON JR. WILL BE HERE TALK ABOUT
HOW THE LEFT AND AMERICA HAS
BEEN TRIGGERED AND THE PRESIDENT
RAISED A GOOD QUESTION, WHAT IF
HUNTER'S NAME WERE DON JR.?
ALSO CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES AND
CONGRESSMAN GATES WILL BE HERE
TONIGHT AND ALSO TONIGHT, I WILL
ADDRESS ALL OF YOUR FAKE NEWS
PEOPLE, YOUR INSANE STORY ABOUT
YOURS TRULY, BECAUSE I DO MY JOB
THAT YOU GUYS DON'T DO BECAUSE
YOU'RE TOO LAZY AND CORRUPT.
FIRST, WE BEGIN WITH A MASSIVE
BREAKING DEVELOPING FROM
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER JOHN
SOLOMON.
CREEPY SLEEPY CRAZY UNCLE
JOE BIDEN IS IN SERIOUS HOT
WATER.
WE WERE RIGHT.
ACCORDING TO SOLOMON, HUNTER
BIDEN WAS IN FACT PEDDLING HIS
INFLUENCE AND WE NOW HAVE ACCESS
TO DAMNING NEW DOCUMENTS TONIGHT
SHOWING HOW HIS COMPANY,
UKRAINIAN OIL AND GAS GIANT
THERESA MAY HOLDINGS, THEY USED
HUNTER BIDEN.
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S SON AT THE
TIME, THE CHILD AT I IN CHARGE
OF UKRAINE AT THE TIME TO TRY
AND WIN SPECIAL FAVOR FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
LOOK AT THIS.
FEBRUARY 2016, JUST ONE MONTH
BEFORE THEN-VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
LEVERAGED 1 BILLION OF YOUR TAX
DOLLARS IN U.S. AID TO FORCE
UKRAINE TO FIRE A PROSECUTOR WHO
WAS INVESTIGATING BURISMA
HOLDINGS AND HIS SON.
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT HIS
SON WAS PAID WITH ZERO
EXPERIENCE IN ENERGY, UKRAINE
GAS AND OIL.
REPRESENTED FOR THE COMPANY WAS
COMMUNICATING WITH YOU ABOUT A
STATE DEPARTMENT WE LEARNED
TONIGHT.
ACCORDING TO THESE NEWLY
UNEARTHED EMAILS COURTESY OF
JOHN SOLOMON AND A FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT REQUEST, THE
BURISMA REP WAS LOBBYING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION TO END
CORRUPTION ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
THEIR COMPANY.
EVEN NOTING THAT "TWO
HIGH-PROFILE U.S. CITIZENS ARE
AFFILIATED WITH THE COMPANY,
INCLUDING HUNTER BIDEN AS A
BOARD MEMBER."
THAT'S JUST ONE MONTH LATER, THE
VICE PRESIDENT TELLS THE COUNTRY
OF UKRAINE.
WHY WERE THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES EVER WANT A
PROSECUTOR OF UKRAINE FIRED?
BY THE PROSECUTOR IN SIX HOURS
OR YOU WON'T GET THE BILLION
DOLLARS.
DON'T BELIEVE ME?
CALL OBAMA.
THAT IS A JOE QUID PRO QUO
BRAGGING ABOUT IT ON TAPE, AND
FOR GOOD MEASURE, LET'S REMIND
YOU OF HIM BRAGGING IN HIS OWN
WORDS, TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE BILLION DOLLARS.
THEY SAID YOU GOT AUTHORITY, YOU
ARE NOT THE PRESIDENT, THE
PRESIDENT -- I SAID "CALL THEM."
AS IF YOU'RE NOT GETTING A
BILLION DOLLARS.
I THINK IT WAS SIX HOURS -- I
SAID "I'M LEAVING IN SIX HOURS.
IF THE PROSECUTOR IS NOT FIRED
IT YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE
MONEY."
WELL SON OF A [BLEEP] GOT FIRED.
>> Sean: SON OF A [BLEEP].
QUID PRO QUO JOE, THAT IS CALLED
A SHAKEDOWN AND CALLING THE
COMPROMISED CORRUPT COWARD AND
CONGENITAL LIAR ADAM SCHIFF,
THERE IS YOUR QUID PRO QUO ON
TAPE.
HE'S BRAGGING ABOUT IT.
BURISMA NAME DROPS HUNTER BIDEN
TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF OBAMA
AND A MONTH LATER THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING HUNTER BIDEN AND
THAT COMPANY, PAYING MILLIONS
WITH NO BACKGROUND OR EXPERIENCE
AFTER BIDEN LEVERAGED A BILLION
OF OUR TAX DOLLARS -- HE'S DONE.
DID HUNTER HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH
OIL AND GAS?
NO.
EXPERIENCE WITH ENERGY?
NONE.
DID HE HAVE EXPERIENCE IN
UKRAINE?
NONE.
BUT IT WAS HIS FATHER WHO WAS
THE SECOND MOST POWERFUL ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND IN CHARGE
OF AMERICAN POLICY IN UKRAINE.
THAT'S CALLED -- PICK YOUR
CHOICE, INFLUENCE PEDDLING,
BUYING FAVOR.
WHAT OTHER POSSIBLE REASON COULD
THERE BE A VICE PRESIDENT
DEMANDING A UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
BE FIRED OR YOU DON'T GET THE
BILLION.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
EVEN HUNTER BIDEN COULD NOT DENY
THIS OBVIOUS FACT.
THIS HAS TO BE THE DUMBEST
INTERVIEW I'VE EVER SEEN A
49-YEAR-OLD GIVE IN MY LIFE.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU DIDN'T HAVE ANY EXTENSIVE
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT NATURAL GAS OR
UKRAINE ITSELF?
>> NO, BUT I THINK I HAD AS MUCH
KNOWLEDGE OF ANYBODY ELSE THAT
WAS ON THE BOARD.
IF NOT MORE.
>> IN THE LIST YOU GAVE ME OF
THE REASONS WHY YOU'RE ON THAT
BOARD, YOU DID NOT LIST THE FACT
THAT YOU WERE THE SON OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> OF COURSE.
>> WHAT ROLE DO YOU THINK THAT
PLAYED?
>> I THINK IT IS IMPOSSIBLE FOR
ME TO BE IN ANY OF THE BOARDS
THAT I JUST MENTIONED WITHOUT
SAYING I'M THE SON OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> IF YOUR LAST NAME WASN'T
BIDEN DO YOU THINK YOU HAVE
ASKED TO BE ON THE BOARD OF
BURISMA?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW.
PROBABLY NOT.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED
IN MY LIFE IF MY LAST NAME
WASN'T BIDEN.
>> Sean: WITH NO EXPERIENCE --
PROBABLY NOT, THEY PROBABLY
WOULDN'T HAVE PAID HIM MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IT LOOKS LIKE BURISMA'S
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN HUNTER BIDEN PAID OFF IN A
VERY BIG WAY.
THEY ALSO GOT, BY THE WAY,
HUNTER $1.5 BILLION PRIVATE
EQUITY DEAL WITH THE BANK OF
CHINA TEN DAYS AFTER FLYING WITH
HIS DAD TO CHINA, ZERO
EXPERIENCE IN CHINA.
WE CAN'T FIND ANY EXPERIENCE IN
PRIVATE EQUITY EITHER.
WOULD ANY OTHER AMERICAN GET
THIS DEAL?
NO.
THIS STINKS TO HIGH HEAVEN.
JOE 30330 SAYS THEY NEVER
DISCUSSED THIS.
REALLY?
IF YOU DIDN'T DISCUSS IT WHY DID
YOU LEVERAGE A BILLION TAX
DOLLARS TO FIRE THE GUY
INVESTIGATING HER SON?
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
AND IT DOESN'T END THERE.
ANOTHER EMAIL SHOWS HUNTER BIDEN
SCORED A ONE-ON-ONE MEETING WITH
THEN-DEPUTY SECRETARY OF STATE
TONY LINCOLN JUST ONE MONTH
AFTER STARTING HIS CUSHY GIG
WITH BURISMA HOLDINGS IN 2015.
IN MARCH OF 2016 WE LEARNED
TONIGHT HUNTER 'HIS BUSINESS
PARTNER AND FELLOW BURISMA BOARD
MEMBER DEVON ARCHER SCORED A
MEETING WITH SECRETARY OF STATE
JOHN KERRY.
SO NICE TO KNOW PEOPLE IN HIGH
PLACES.
THIS IS A IS A BEHIND-THE-SCENES
LOOK, IT REVEALS A LEVEL OF SICK
NEPOTISM AND INFLUENCE PEDDLING.
IT IS REPULSIVE AND SHOULD
DISCUSSED EVERY AMERICAN.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GET IT.
THE MEDIA MOB, ALL THEY DO IS
RUN DEFENSE FOR THE BIDENS.
THAT'S EQUALLY REPULSIVE AND
SICK AND IT SHOWS WHO THE MEDIA
IS.
NOW, THE PRESIDENT RAISED THIS
IN A SPEECH TONIGHT, WHAT THEY
MAKE THESE EXCUSES OFF IF IT WAS
DONALD TRUMP JR. WITH NO
EXPERIENCE BEING PAID MILLIONS?
I DOUBT IT.
AND ACCORDING TO FOX'S LEGAL
ANALYST, PLENTY STOMACH PAY
CLOSE ATTENTION, GREGG JARRETT
WILL JOIN US IN A MINUTE,
BIDEN'S ACTIONS COULD BE
CRIMINAL.
GREGG JARRETT, LOOK AT YOUR
SCREEN, HAS IDENTIFIED THE LAWS,
EXTREMELY APPLICABLE TO ALL OF
US.
FOREIGN CORRUPT PRACTICES ACT.
15 USC, 78, QUOTE, "IT IS
ILLEGAL FOR A U.S. TO COERCE OR
INFLUENCE, THROUGH BRIBERY OR
EXTORTION, A FOREIGN NATION INTO
TAKING ACTION -- MIGHT
FINANCIALLY BENEFIT THAT PERSON,
HIS FAMILY OR BUSINESS."
HUNTER, THAT SEEMS TO FIT.
AND ACCORDING TO GREGG JARRETT,
THE VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN USED
HIS PUBLIC OFFICE, VP, TO
INFLUENCE AND COERCE A   A FOR
OFFICIAL TO TAKING ACTION THAT
BENEFITED BIDEN'S SON, AND BIDEN
HAS LOOKED BROKEN THE LAW.
IF BRIBERY 201C, WHOEVER
CORRUPTLY GIVES, OFFERS,
PROMISES, ANYTHING OF VALUE, A
BILLION DOLLARS, TO A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL, TO INFLUENCE AN
OFFICIAL ACT -- FIRE HIM.
HE IS GUILTY OF BRIBERY.
FIRE THE GUY, YOU GET A BILLION
DOLLARS.
AGAIN, HOW ABOUT THE GRATUITIES
ASK?
18 USC 201B, GIVING, OFFERING OR
PROMISING ANYTHING OF VALUE TO A
PUBLIC OFFICIAL, UKRAINE,
1 BILLION, IN EXCHANGE FOR ANY
OFFICIAL ACT -- FIRE HIM, SIX
HOURS -- LOOKS BAD.
AND LOOK AT THE HOBBS ACT, 18
USC 1951, A THREAT TO A FOREIGN
OFFICIAL IN ORDER TO OBTAIN AN
OFFICIAL BENEFIT AFFECTING ANY
FOREIGN STATE OF COMMERCE
WOULD -- EXTORTION.
I WILL LET LAW-ENFORCEMENT TO
THEIR JOBS BUT I THINK WE NOW
NEED AN OFFICIAL CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION OPENED HERE.
THIS ALMOST LOOKS TO ME LIKE A
BIDEN CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE, BUT
WHAT DO I KNOW?
I'M JUST A TALK SHOW HOST AND A
MEMBER OF THE PRESS.
IT MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING TO DO --
I WOULD HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH IT UNTIL NO MATTER IF I WAS
THE PROSECUTOR.
THERE YOU HAVE IT, BIDEN RIGHT
AT THE TOP, THE SECOND MOST
POWERFUL PERSON IN THE COUNTRY,
HIS SON RAKING IN MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
WITH NO EXPERIENCE.
THE EASY GIG ON THE BOARD OF
BURISMA HOLDINGS.
NO OTHER AMERICAN IS GOING TO
GET THAT DEAL.
NO OTHER AMERICAN IS GETTING
$1.5 BILLION PRIVATE EQUITY DEAL
WITH THE BANK OF CHINA WITH NO
EXPERIENCE.
IT MAY BANK, GOLDMAN SACHS, THEY
MIGHT BE MORE SUITABLE FOR CHINA
MIGHT BE MORE SUITABLE FOR CHIN.
THE MEDIA MOB, THE WILLING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS STEPPING ALL
OVER THEMSELVES TRYING TO
PROTECT THE BIDEN'S.
FOR YEARS THEY SIMPLY LOOKED THE
OTHER WAY, IGNORED THIS MASSIVE
SCANDAL, JUST LIKE THEY ALWAYS
PROTECTED THE CLINTONS AND FOR
MONTHS NOW, THEY HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO COVER IT ALL UP,
TELLING ITS ALL THIS PROVEN
CONSPIRACY THEORY -- THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OF ANY WRONGDOING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SMARTER.
DEMOCRATS ON THE HILL, EVEN
BIDEN'S 2020 OPPONENTS, THEY ARE
DOING EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER
TO PROTECT BIDEN, ALTHOUGH     L
TO PROTECT BIDEN, ALTHOUGH     U
TO PROTECT BIDEN, ALTHOUGH     C
TO PROTECT BIDEN, ALTHOUGH     I
TO PROTECT BIDEN, ALTHOUGH     G
TO PROTECT BIDEN, ALTHOUGH     A
WITCH HUNT HE DIDN'T GET
ANYTHING.
THAT'S HOW MORALLY BANKRUPT --
THAT'S HOW INTELLECTUALLY
LAZY -- THAT'S HOW
COMPROMISED -- THAT'S HOW
CORRUPT AND THAT'S HOW
HYPOCRITICAL YOU HAVE TO BE TO
BE EITHER A DEMOCRAT, OR PART OF
THE LIEN MOB IN THE MEDIA.
IT ONLY MAKES SENSE THAT THEIR
DE FACTO LEADER IS A -- YEAH,
THAT GUY?
HE IS A CORRUPT, COMPROMISED
COWARD AND CONGENITAL LIAR.
HE'S BEEN LYING TO US FOR THREE
YEARS.
HIS NAME?
ADAM SCHIFF, AND A FAKE PHONY
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER
HEARSAY WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO IS
REFUSING TO COME OUT OF THE